uh do you because i feel like your buzz
is like really catching fire um
what do you think like uh
has been the difference in the last like
12 months or so since shit's really
catching fire for you in terms of just
like was it things you were doing
differently was it a certain record that
went crazy like why do you think like
you got the most eyes on you like right
now i feel like the moment i'm going
crazy right now you know what i'm saying
because my brother smirk hopped up on
the [ __ ] my cousin yeah
he hopped on that record so a lot of mo
people reaching out and saying [ __ ] i
hate
seeing the message like hey oh i ain't
even see this what up like you know like
everybody everything falling in place
since since bro hopped on a record with
me yeah i feel like we always talk about
how people get the drake stimulus
package yeah there's like a such thing
as a dirk stimulus package this thing so
nine days bro my daughter
when dirk is on a wreck
[ __ ] career around like folks hop on
the record i mean we talked about vanzo
he had up the skull which i feel like
yeah really put him in a different space
dirk hopped on a [ __ ] took him
out of that boston ritchie's dirk
blood golden in this [ __ ] he's stamp
[ __ ] for sure